Today, I am proud to announce the Walt Disney Company is acquiring Lucasfilm,...
...the global entertainment company founded by George Lucas,...
...and the home of the legendary Star Wars franchise.
Fans can expect a new feature film, Star Wars Episode 7, in theaters worldwide in 2015.
And there will be more feature films, as well as consumer products,...
...television projects, games, and theme park attractions.
We've got a plan for 7, 8, 9, which is the end of the trilogy...
...and other films also.
So, we have a large group of ideas and characters and books and all kinds of things.
We could go on making Star Wars for the next hundred years.
I realized, at some point, I needed to retire,...
...and I wanted to go on and do other things,...
...things in philanthropy and doing more experimental kinds of films,...
...but I couldn't really drag my company into that.
I've been a big fan of Disney all my life,...
...from when I was born, first day at Disneyland.
I love Disney movies.
I look at it as I'm investing in Disney 'cause that's my retirement funds.